Jenny baby doughnuts the smaller than a
baby hey guys it's Katie and I'm here
with my husband Chris hi he's back this
week round of applause
you guys asked for it I didn't go
anywhere so Chris there is a trend
that's happening all over the Internet
where people are making mini pancakes
cereal Wow
yeah do you want to see yes I do oh my
god well good that's pretty great and I
hope you're not excited because I'm not
making that what I'm thinking donut
cereal cereal that sounds really good so
you're just gonna take those little
donut holes or munchkins no I'm gonna
make it from scratch but I guess that
should obvious that sounds really
delicious donut let me down I won't
I won't let ya so I'm gonna try to make
donut cereal but not just any type of
donut funfetti donuts cuz a it's easier
to use a cake box and B who doesn't love
sprinkles and everything I do first
thing I'm gonna do is preheat the oven
at 350 degrees preheat done now I'm
going to disregard the instructions on
the back of this box because we want to
make a thick batter that we can pipe out
not a runny cake batter so grab whatever
cake batter you have and add it to a
medium bowl then we're gonna add one egg
some oil some water and then whisk that
right up that funfetti smells like
birthday she is thick that was really
easy let's get this into a piping bag
and we'll line some baking sheets with
parchment so I have my baking sheets
with my parchment and I got my piping
bag for my tip I'm using a small to
medium rounded tip and whenever you're
filling a piping bag it's easiest to
fill using a tall glass or container and
then you're just gonna fill that in
[Music]
great take a water break fresh so the
next parts gonna be super easy just have
to pipe out like a thousand perfect
circles I'm sure I can do it to make my
life a little bit easier I'm gonna pipe
a little bit of batter into each corner
to help hold the parchment down here we
go perfect circle probably not gonna
happen on the first try but we'll see
alright here goes nothing
[Music]
the batter kind of overlapped it's not
exactly flat so I'm gonna just dip my
finger in a little water and I'm just
gonna Pat that down
alright cue this going very fast I'm
gonna go put these in the oven for about
seven to eight minutes and we'll see how
it works out good luck
[Music]
this isn't really good I'm really
pleased a few of them lost the hole in
the center so we're gonna make some
doughnut holes I'll take this straw and
we're just gonna poke a hole right
through it
and you've got a perfect doughnut with a
doughnut hole once all your doughnuts
are perfect you can move them on to a
drying rack next we're gonna make what I
think is the most important part of any
doughnut the glaze so we're gonna start
off with two cups of powdered sugar add
meringue powder to that this is just
gonna help our glaze stiffen up faster
and then we'll just sift those two
things together and next time I'm gonna
use a bigger bowl cuz this one is way
too small for this I don't notice they
came this is so funny me delicately
trying not to get this all over the
place next we're gonna add four
tablespoons of water and I love a pink
glazed donut so to make that perfect
pink color we're gonna do three drops of
purple food coloring and six drops of
pink I lost count as I was talking
hopefully this turns out to be the right
color and you're gonna whisk that right
up okay
our glaze is gorgeous simply gorgeous
so now it's time to put it on top of our
little babies start in this corner well
I'm going to glaze a few at a time so
that I can add the sprinkles before the
frosting hardens
[Music]
these are ice that they look very very
cute I'm gonna go throw these into a
breakfast bowl and we'll go grab Chris
crab
[Music]
here you go fun in a ball oh my god this
is like a partay yeah these are cool
looks like a cereal that someone would
be eating in a cartoon can we try yes
let's do it
so donut celebration it's a cookie cake
mouthful good cookie cuckoo crazy
cookies that's not stealing a slogan
from another cereal what would this look
gonna be tiny baby down baby Donuts
Johnny baby Donuts the smaller than a
baby thank you so much that was tasty
I'll taste do you know that but maybe
like come
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]